oui on les a menés dans les commentaires
il s'était déjà existé déjà partis sans
qu on ait pu rien faire
justement directement sur le coup sa
voix jeune soldat qui était arrivé au
mali ya seulement un mois
c'était la première fois que tu voyais
la mort d'être confronté à la mort comme
ça oui c'était direct et violent
[Musique]
on
c'est un engin artisanal une mine de
tout simplement qui a qui a explosé sur
leur passage c'est un peu de trois
étoiles qui nous protège
je garde
sur le coup on n'a pas une envie de
vengeance un peu sur le coup si envie de
de tout casser on a envie de choquer le
premier et miki passé lui met la misère
ça c'est un sentiment
qui a été longtemps en nous mais faut
quand même faire preuve de jugement et
de d'être sûr que ce soit en ennemi que
ne fasse pas de de dommages collatéraux
et est-ce qu'on est toujours les mêmes
l'adressage forcément nom n'est pas le
même on change littéralement on prend
plus conscience que la vie est quelque
chose de très précieux on se rend compte
que les petites choses du quotidien
basse et c'est très important c'est
quelque chose d'incroyable
donc on change profondément déjà sur nos
divisions de vie
[Musique]
c'est vraiment pas trop les sites à
pendant quatre points bas
c'est ça ma crème forcément où il fait
comment parler tous les soirs il a
tellement hâte
voilà d'accord
non y'a pas 5e à temps c'est important
toujours rigoler ensemble c'est ça
permet de garder une transe morale
importante qui utilisent des bombes
forcément vous avez vu un peu ok je suis
peut-être jeunes de ces résilience
résidence c'est ce que c'est c'est
l'opération cela tape à cydia
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]